put out these comedy specials 13 years
like a locust you have returned with
these why did you decide to put two of
them out with money money yeah I did I
did you know I I just started making
them I made them and then I shelled them
and then they bought them did you did
you make them thinking oh I'll sell
these one day or do you think like oh
well these might not be so timely
anymore I mean which you know they they
are certainly but did you worry about
that no no not at all
no because it's like I don't get mad at
a photograph because it's not today I
[Laughter]
used to live in in the hood as they
called me - yeah it's very I thought I'd
try it I stick out a little bit Dakota
you're brave a lot of white people are
afraid to walk through Harlem the stuff
late at night and you got to remember
that the black people could be just
afraid of you as you of them you know
I'm going to get mug to beat up and I'm
black blue thinking oh my god it's a cop
he's not fooling us everyone act natural
that's the problem
he might look like Conan O'Brien
where did you forever where you first
met the roots and in the yeah I was in I
was important main do you remember that
yeah and I was walking in a mall and I
guess you guys had been there an hour
before me so they just thought I was
like a lost route - she's like I love
the route like the routes now have you
had any trouble with that you have an
auntie trouble at the police have you
you don't get it you know no not at all
but I have a police scanner yeah it
looks like a Walkman people think I'm
listening to music but I'm getting
important information she just walking
down the street listening to a police
scanner yeah you might hear something
calling all cars calling all cars be on
the lookout for a black male between
four seven and six eight I'm better get
off the streets for a minute now you had
your uh you had the Dave Chappelle show
at Comedy Central and then you didn't
have the Dave Chappelle show at Comedy
Central and and and and in comedy the
reason most people have a show and then
don't have a show is because they say
well we don't want you to have a show
anymore but that wasn't the case here
the case here was you said I guess you
said I don't want your show anymore and
you took a hike it's really it's worse
yeah what now are you tired of talking
about us ten years overseas I don't talk
about it it's like you know I just you
know listen here it is technically I
never quit I'm seven years late for work
boy are you gonna be in trouble when you
go back you know no it's like it's like
getting divorced in the 50s people
didn't go to divorce court they just
look at their wife like baby I don't go
get a pack of cigarettes I'll be right
back
did you think though that I mean a lot
of people now feel like Oh Clinton lied
to us did you feel like you know the
president lied to you or well that's why
I like them because yes he did lied to
us very well that was one of the better
lies you've seen in politics you know
what I mean
yeah yeah we let it good was that is
that we knew he was last but what later
the masterpiece is that he knew that we
knew that he was right we went out there
and he lied with confidence we'll never
forget Comedy Central your former that's
where the show was they should have been
on the air two years maybe three years
yeah shoot not third seat and you were
and they there's a negotiation to
renegotiation and they said here we're
gonna give you we're gonna guarantee you
and enormous sum of money to continue
doing the show because it's so
successful and then you apparently you
agreed to it and then where did he go
the show stopped and never came back and
like you said seven years later you're
just late for work so what a decision
was made you made a decision
yeah I made a series of decisions do you
regret saying I don't want this enormous
sum of money well okay look Dave it's
very hard to go through something like
this because no one's really done it
before so there's not too many people
that don't think I'm crazy right so I
look at her like this I'm gonna
restaurant with my wife it's a nice
restaurant we eating dinner I look
across the room I say you see this guy
over here across the room he has a
hundred million dollars and we're eating
the same entree so okay fine I don't
have fifty million dollars or whatever
woods let's say I have ten million in
the bank the difference in lifestyle is
excu the only difference between having
ten million hours and fifty million
hours is an astounding 40 million
dollars you saw that movie planet eggs
with Mark Wahlberg the remake yeah well
yeah they're both racist to me man like
the first one was like was like you know
just get your damn dirty ape hands up
and like all come on what are you really
talking about and then I've seen a new
one I'm thinking and this is a more
progressive time this will not be his
racist and then they had the Apes was
sitting at dinner yeah I'm not even
making stuff they was eating watermelon
I was like oh and then later on in the
movie they read it from the Apes and
they run the water cuz the Apes can't
swim
[Laughter]
she's like all word busy these aids can
talking but they can't swim at the end
it's like when I've seen the ape smoking
a new port I just gotta
you know America has a racial hot seat I
think we can all agree that that's the
truth and we can also agree that that
hot seat is traditionally occupied by
African Americans in general
african-american men in particular
although I can see that in recent years
that seat has been occupied by by
Mexicans and I dare say Arabs and we the
black Americans would like to thank you
both for your sacrifice of a struggle we
needed a break we all go through
something but at least I can leave my
backpack someplace backpack you got
about 20 minutes before they send that
robot to blow your [ __ ] up because all
that engineering homework goodbye
through had I hadn't experienced with
the Klan
that's a blazer that you asked me that I
don't talk about this much they came to
my house when I was little it was real
scary that came in the middle of the
night on horseback it's really freaked
everyone in my neighborhood out cuz you
know we didn't know what people were
doing all horses in the middle of the
city but they came they burn across you
on the sidewalk they were singing racist
songs beating on the door old
belligerent black sons of [ __ ]
she'll leave my brother we were like
horrified we were just hiding in the
closet keeping out but my mother this is
a strong woman my mother she went right
to the door and opened it and gave him
candy
[Applause]
you know I saw your baby very nice come
babies how old's the baby now he got
he's 18 months now
that's very cool we can't quite talk
here but that's what I'm waiting for
yeah yeah phone to talk yeah cuz what
have you ever had a conversation with a
guy that lived in your balls cold were
you when you made your first TV
development deal nineteen my mother and
my grandmother will freaked out you know
I was the first person in my family not
to go to college that had not been a
slave right
so I was really breaking from tradition
and it was like a graduation lunch we
were having and they had my dad come and
talk to me and my dad takes me outside
and he's like listen and this is some
advice applies to all you acting
students he says the big actor is a
lonely life everybody wants to make it
and you might not make it and I said my
dad well well that depends on what
making it is there was smart smartass
kid
yeah it spins on but making it is there
he says what do you mean I said well
you're a teacher I said if I couldn't
make a teacher salary doing comedy I
think that's better than being a teacher
and he started laughing you say if you
keep that attitude I think you should go
he said but name your price in the
beginning if it ever gets more expensive
than the price your name get out of it
would you ever ride a bull even for you
try it at all I could win a rodeo cheap
well you do how do you can't cheat in a
rodeo I could right before let me out
that little bull stable I'll blow weed
in the bull's face appeal has been on
that bull for a record four hours
[Applause]
the bull is now having a snack there's
no simply for hours you'd be gone